hey guys my name is Justin I've got your
Tuesday dose of GameSpot news already to
get
that's up Bastian developer supergiant
games have revealed their next game
called hire the party based RPG set to
land on ps4 and PC in 2017 the game
calls feed adventure through a vast
mystical purgatory leading a group of
exiles as you take part in an ancient
competition that offers up the chance to
return home supergiant have said the
game will have rich atmospheric
presentation and storytelling as well as
gameplay that combines expressive
decision-making on the world map with
fast action packed confrontations
against rival groups of exiles you'll
meet all sorts of characters and dig
deeper into the truth of the mysterious
competition called the right 2k have
revealed that mafia 3 is going to land
on october seven of next year and they
threw a new trailer our way for good
measure mafia three puts you in the
shoes of the link and clay and the large
emphasis of the game is going to be on
the racism and prejudice against
african-americans that was present in
the deep south in 1968 2k also announced
that everyone who pre-orders Mafia 3
will get their hands on something called
the family kickback which contains three
exclusively talent themed vehicles and
weapons whatever that means in addition
to the standard version of the game
there will also be an eighty dollar
limited deluxe pack which includes the
game and season pass and a 150 dollar to
collectors edition which contain those
two things as well as the game score on
vinyl a collectible art book art prints
and other yet-to-be-announced items the
game will arrive on ps4 pc and xbox one
finally even more details have arrived
about the upgraded ps4 code names neo
and this time from Eurogamer since giant
bombs original info dump yesterday on
documents they had obtained referring to
the room with console from Sony's
Eurogamer has come forward to
corroborate the story Eurogamer has
added that dev kit prototypes are on
their way to studios right now and the
test kit and second gen dev kit are set
to follow in the coming months that said
these kits are not going to match the
final systems design and reportedly Sony
are planning to provide more intensive
briefings on the near system at its
Devlin event in May Giant Bomb revealed
yesterday that the near ps4 model will
feature an upgraded CPU GPU and ram
adding that every ps4 game will need to
ship with two modes to cater to the base
ps4 and the higher powered near view
school let me know down in that comment
box if you'd be keen on buying a higher
powered kiss or I'll be shot ahead
schemes but but we've got stories on hot
stone and street ratified that is
everything I've got for you today but do
let me know what you think about today's
stories and I will see you again
tomorrow